se suman voces en contra del proyecto de
constitución del presidente karzai &
hamma hammami un líder político de
izquierda quien estuvo encarcelado y
torturado desde 1972 hasta 2011 ve como
una amenaza para el país al actual
presidente de túnez
viví todas las dictaduras que vivió
túnez viví la dictadura de burguiba
penal y viví los 10 años posteriores a
la revolución con su fracaso la
corrupción y los asesinatos políticos
con el movimiento en acta y sus aliados
nada
marc hoy vivo otra etapa que es la de la
tiranía del populista caixa y xavi
el con otros cientos de opositores
salieron el sábado en las calles de la
capital tunecina para protestar contra
una carta magna que le otorga a casi
todos los poderes al presidente elimina
la mayoría de los controles sobre su
autoridad
he venido a participar como mujer
tunecina y a decir que nos adherimos a
la constitución de 2014
y que decimos no al referendo no a la
constitución de un solo hombre no a la
reunión de poderes en manos de una
persona
no a la destrucción de las instituciones
en túnez letras
[Música]
el nuevo texto pretende sustituir el
sistema mixto presidencialista
parlamentario que fue consagrado en la
constitución de 2014 que vio como túnez
era elogiada como la única democracia
surgida de las revueltas de la primavera
árabe de 2011 el 25 de julio de 2021
ayer destituyó al gobierno suspendió el
parlamento y desde entonces gobierna por
decreto y ha prometido en repetidas
ocasiones que no se convertirá en un
dictador este lunes 92 millones de
tunecinos están llamados a las urnas y
aunque según los observadores los
tunecinos rechazarán la consulta prevén
que la constitución terminará siendo
aprobada